and let's bring you a little bit more on
the latest covert data the react one
team from imperial college london uh now
completing the latest round of their
study looking at the prevalence of the
virus across the country uh we're joined
now by professor paul elliott director
of the react program and chair in
epidemiology and public health medicine
at imperial college london great to see
you this morning professor um it is
again a fascinating piece of research
let's let's start with that which
everyone has has latched on to how much
more do we know about omicron
well what we've seen in our data is um
that we've had
since the summer really quite high
prevalence but but pretty steady with
the r number around one
but from the beginning of december we
saw this very dramatic rise in uh
prevalence across the country but
particularly in london
with the r number now substantially
above one so this exponential increase
in infections which is
absolutely being driven by the omicron
variant
just in terms of of what that means in
terms of the public health strategy in
terms of pressure on the nhs you will
have seen i'm sure some of the front
pages this morning and everyone focusing
very very quickly on the fact that that
it certainly appears that this is
significantly
significantly less severe that there is
a reduced chance of hospitalization
as a result i mean how confident are we
in that
well of course that that's encouraging
news uh that perhaps the infection when
you get it might be
less severe in in terms of
hospitalization
but of course with this very very rapid
rise and increase in cases and and we've
seen the
national cases go above 100 000
and of course uh
more cases means more pressure because
if
if
even though a smaller proportion might
get severe disease or going to hospital
that could still result in in many cases
and of course that could give pressure
on the health service
of course i mean just just very simply
put
despite the fact that omicron may prove
to be significantly less severe than
individual kind of health outcomes that
does not mean that the nhs will not be
under huge pressure perhaps in a couple
of weeks time
absolutely the case because
this
rise in
infections uh which we see in our data
and is seen also in the uh testing data
through through the national routine
testing of people presenting with
symptoms
means that there are going to be well
there are you know many many cases and
sadly some of those people may get
severe illness and end up in hospital
of course this data will assist um other
pieces of research the modeling
around um covert 19 and of course
on the new the new variant
a number of people are suggesting that
the spy m models were quite pessimistic
they would need to be revised on the
basis of of what you have discovered is
is that correct
yeah i mean what we're doing is uh we're
looking actually in real time so our
data was up till
the 14th of december with some
additional
cases up until the 17th of december and
we're looking in the general population
so we take a random sample of the
population of england and ask people to
take part and give us a swab and answer
some questions about their symptoms and
so forth so we get a really good picture
of what's happening in the population in
real time and of course that's extremely
helpful so we're not modeling forward
we're looking at what's happening in the
here and now and here and now
as i say we've seen this very rapid rise
in infections which is being driven by
the omicron variant
but of course it will be a piece of
research that the government would look
at in terms of you know plotting their
their strategy moving forward i i wonder
though if you could just focus just for
a second on on children the idea that
4.5 percent infected there compared to
1.5 percent naturally
do we do we know why that is is it
simply you know the lack of vaccination
well we we we have a if you like a sort
of natural experiment because the
younger children have not been
vaccinated so this is the primary
school-aged children whereas
the older children from 12 and above
have been
receiving vaccine and and in our data
certainly
uh a good proportion of them have been
vaccinated and very interestingly what
we saw from our previous survey which
ended on the 5th of november to the
current survey
which was between the 23rd of november
and the 15th of december we saw a a drop
by about half of the infection rate in
the older school children
but the youngest children you're talking
about their prevalence remained about
the same about five percent
so so we do see the the real benefits of
the vaccination program in those older
school children coming through in the
data that we're collecting
what does the what does the research
show about about those who have yet to
be vaccinated we know that there are
parts of london for example where
perhaps as many as 40 of the population
haven't had a single jab
there must be concern about what might
be happening there
yes certainly in our data the the real
the really big rise in december with
with domicron has been in london it's
it's sort of in the vanguard if you like
of this of this variant
and um
of the ten
uh local small areas uh
lower tier local authority areas that
we're we're we're monitoring
of the 10 with the highest eight of
those are in london
so we really are seeing this in london
um professor just whilst we have you i
wonder if i might ask you to kind of
remove your professorial hat just for a
second um
on the basis of the the research that
has been carried out as we edge into to
2022 past couple of years have been
pretty rough for everyone are you
feeling more or less positive about what
might be coming down the track as a
result of this
uh to be honest we were really quite
positive about the rollout of the
vaccine program which has been obviously
a fantastic success
uh we are seeing that in our data not
only in the um
secondary school-aged children but
actually in older people over the age of
65 we've seen a real drop in infections
in that group
again reflecting
the booster program where most of those
people have had a booster so it was
really looking
looking promising
and of course now we've got this variant
and uh
and this very very sharp rise in
infection so for the time being
i would say that we all have to be a bit
cautious
and we have to pay attention to the
public health message we have to wear
our mask and so forth
because um you know these are
unprecedented levels of infection
they certainly are um professor paul
elliott great to have you on the program
this morning and a very merry christmas
to you and yours when it comes thanks
very much thank you